everybody my name is chef Marcus Sampson
and I'm gonna talk to you about one of
my favorite things fried chicken what
open Red Rooster it was clear to me we
have to have New York's best fried
chicken to go about it was very personal
to me I did not grow up with fried
chicken it's something I learned to love
when I came to America I want to do
something that was inspired by Harlem
but also put my own accent to it one of
the reasons why I became a chef is
because my grandmother Helga she cook
every meal for us growing up and Isis to
her I was a little sous chef and the
love and encouragement I got from my
grandmother was really one of the
reasons why I became a chef cooking is
really my favorite thing to do
anytime I finding new ingredients or get
introduced to new flavor I go really
crazy and I love it and nothing to lose
to so many different cultures and each
one really something I bring back a new
technique and you mess it and I'm always
trying to bring it into my kitchen and
it's one of my favorite things about
cooking that you never quite stop
learning we got two different recipes
one is traditional and one is really
inspired by a Mexican sauce so the first
recipe it sort of goes back and forth
between being super traditional but then
there's also some choices and some left
turns that we do right it's all about
packing the birds with great flavors
fried chicken for me it's almost like a
noise the sound that you want out of it
should be super crunchy on the outside
and moist on the inside
fried chicken for me such an iconic
recipe to speak sort of to American
culture very often southern American
culture I want to listen to some really
good music sit outside eating with my
hands and just shared with some friends
you know that's living that's the life
so I'm from Ethiopia and the main spice
blend in Ethiopia is called better para
so for my chicken shake the main
ingredient is better bread it's a
beautiful sort of mild chili blend this
is to make sure that the chicken gets
this smoky beautiful spicy flavor that
makes our fried chicken so very special
this dish I was really intimidated by
right you know I'm 50 yards away from
Sylvia the most famous African
arrested in the country and they have
really good fried chicken so for me I
really thought about how to do different
and not serving the white meat serving
dark meat
bone-in helped me really sort of take a
stand on what type of chicken we want to
serve the other thing that was important
for me was this crispy sound and when
the skin is really crackling and super
crispy that's a happy sound to me it's
when your fried chicken at home you want
to fry it twice not once but twice the
second fry only fried for three minutes
it's gonna be super crispy supe
delicious when I walk through the dining
room and I hear that sound and I hear
like people are really excited about
gliding into the chicken you know they
have the bib on the tie if there were
ties probably on the side the hands are
little bit messy they're biting into the
chicken that's a party that's eating
fried chicken that's red dirt
so the second recipe gonna see is really
taking my influences from Mexico and
Latin cooking's all about packing the
bird with great flavors and in this
sauce here there's really inspired by a
Mexican male so it's chocolate we have
beer
we have chilies we have onions by the
way this chocolate sauce is amazing you
can use it with grilled lamb with
grilled pork it's an amazing sauce that
would work with any type of protein but
for me it's perfection used with a fried
chicken one of my secrets is our chicken
shake it is delicious I put it on
everything so this they should really
come from I love for fried chicken you
might have heard of it we have a place
called Red Rooster where the bird is
came
[Music]
now just give it a good old shake
sometimes I call it chicken snow and you
get it this is absolutely delicious so I
got water gonna bring this to your board
we solved and then when it's cooled down
we're gonna pour it on top of the
chicken I love to brine my chicken if
you want to really do some bird there's
a couple of steps you want to do bone-in
dark meat and brine the bird put a lid
on let it sit minimum two hours or
overnight so the marinade I love this
marinade so I did this from my buddy
James who actually did the sauce on a
beef brisket
it was so good and James he just loves
Mexican food and I love Mexican food so
we took the chocolate sauce up in love
with Fried Chicken marry the two
together toss toss there it is
key step the chocolate sauce
and this chocolate sauce is so rich and
delicious and you're gonna see why it's
all about the spices and flavor that
we're gonna add on to this dish
food for me it's all about flavor but
making great flavors takes time
got a little bit heat here I'm gonna add
in the chillies and adding as much sure
like it's a rich song right so it's beer
chocolate spices all simmer together
we're gonna let this simmer and then
it's gonna add in chocolate and butter
this sauce is good for any time you want
to grill or you want to fry something I
will brush the sauce on top it will be
delicious so I'm gonna dredge it the
same lean on the cornstarch all there
for flour they're all there to make it
crunchy we're just gonna whisk that I
love decent oil I'm just flinging the
garlic when I heat up the oil to put in
big gulp close in and then I'm taking
them out just for flavor right and it's
12 minutes then let it rest a resting
for the key so it stays nice and juicy
we got a beautiful chocolate sauce in
there right look at that nice this is so
delicious now we're just gonna have a
little bit of heat finish to brighten up
with a little bit of fresh herb
I love eating this dish with my friends
fry it because there's a dish way talk
about finger smacking finger licking
good good it's rich and delicious and
it's also something to do the spring and
summer eyes you wait for those picnics
you wait for those barbecues everyone in
your family is gonna love this meal I
guarantee you one of the reason why I
love sharing my recipes like this is
because I want people to get excited and
have a recipe that really works well you
know for me as a chef it's all about
sharing all about trust and have an
experience that's gonna be super
delicious and creating memories with
your friends and families and this
recipe I guarantee you it's fun if
delicious it's gonna be yours you can go
and make it again and again again
cooking for me is all about CD you own
curiosity Fried Chicken is not something
I grew up we have to learn it
dolt it could be hard as a chef you're
stubborn but for me it was just quick
like I never had fried chicken until I
was like probably 22 23 I loved it and I
was like I want to learn how to make
this and I want to learn how to make a
better version this is my better version
these are two takes
now that yours go out and cook it that
promise you you will join
[Music]